la révision du procès de patrick dils
c'est désormais chose acquise vous savez
le tueur en série francis heaulme étant
suspecté d'avoir assassiné deux enfants
86 pour lequel patrick dils était en
prison depuis 14 ans nouvel élément de
ce dossier avec les déclarations d'un
codétenu qui affirme avoir recueilli les
confidences de francis heaulme sur sa
culpabilité
valérie ermite christine bost ces gens
mais vous sert ce ne serait qu'une
confession qui n'a pas valeur d'aveu
mais une confession si elle était avérée
pour le moins troublante fin décembre
francis heaulme se serait entretenu avec
d'autres détenus dans sa prison de metz
pressé de dire pourquoi il n'avoue est
passé de meurtres pour lesquels il est
soupçonné
voici quelle aurait été sa réponse
rapportée par l'avocate d'un des
prisonniers
je ne peux pas reconnaître ces faits
sinon ma soeur ne viendrait plus me voir
au parloir est un élément important pour
des personnes condamnées à perpétuité le
parloir c'est quand même la seule chose
qui les retient quelque part à la vie il
a ajouté aussi de toute façon dit il
s'en tire donc deuxième raison pourquoi
vous est quelque chose qui risque de
poser de graves problèmes au sein de la
table
pourquoi faire ça alors que de toute
façon on utilise devrait s'en tirer
heaulme selon ce détenu aurait également
ajouté plusieurs détails comme le chemin
qu'il aurait emprunté pour rejoindre les
voies ferrées là où les deux enfants ont
été tués l'un des hommes qui auraient
recueilli ses confidences se dit
aujourd'hui prêt à témoigner
officiellement devant la justice des
confidences qui n'ont jamais existé
proteste l'avocate de francis heaulme
heaulme ce soir ni farouchement s'être
épanché parole contre parole
l'avocat de patrick dils attend lui une
attestation écrite de la part du
codétenu de francis heaulme pour en
faire et pas lors de la prochaine
demande de mise en liberté de patrick
dils